From the origins of Optimus Primal and the
threat of Scourge, to the influence of the
'90s TV series "Beast Wars," here is all you
need to know before seeing "Transformers:
Rise of the Beasts."
"Transformers: Rise of the Beasts" hits theaters
in 2023.
It was originally set to premiere on June
24, 2022, however, the seventh installment
of the robot franchise was bumped back by
almost a full year.
Now, the film is set to be released on June
9, 2023, in the United States, Canada, and
the U.K.
It will arrive in some European countries,
including Italy, France, and Iceland, a little
earlier, premiering on June 7.
Other countries such as Australia and New
Zealand will have to wait a little longer,
until June 22, to see the film.
June 2023 will be a pretty crowded month for
blockbusters and tentpole movies.
"Rise of the Beasts" will find itself competing
against some pretty awesome 2023 releases
such as "Elemental," "Spider-Man: Across the
Spider-Verse," and "The Flash."
"Rise of the Beasts" has a comparable budget
to "The Flash," coming in at $200 million.
But with the controversy surrounding the film's
lead, Ezra Miller, it's unclear how the highly
anticipated movie will fare.
So, we'll be fascinated to see if "Rise of
the Beasts" can defeat its theatrical foes
and claim the title of the summer movie champion.
"Rise of the Beasts" sees the Autobots and
Decepticons duking it out again, while also
ushering in new characters and a different
story to breathe life into the franchise.
The seventh "Transformers" installment, which
is set in 1994, will follow a veteran named
Noah, a man who loves his family and is looking
for redemption for past mistakes.
The female co-lead is named Elena, a museum
researcher whose knowledge of artifacts will
no doubt factor heavily into the plot.
It's possible that through her work, she,
Noah, and the Autobots discover the existence
of three new tribes of Cybertronians: the
reptilian Predacons, the villainous Terrorcons,
and the heroic Maximals, who all make their
debut in this film.
While Optimus Prime and Bumblebee have often
been the most notable Autobots, taking the
lead in the original trilogy and the 2018
prequel respectively, it's Mirage who forms
the closest bond with the humans in this film.
He'll likely be Noah and Elena's introduction
to the Autobots, the same way that Bumblebee
was for Sam Witwicky.
The movie's official synopsis doesn't reveal
a lot, but it does confirm that the Maximals
will ally themselves with the Autobots in
a battle against the Terrorcons, Predacons,
and Decepticons.
Since this is a prequel, we know that the
heroes don't succeed in wiping out the Decepticons,
but fan-favorite characters like Optimus Prime
and Bumblebee will live to fight another day.
For the most part, the "Transformers" franchise
is Michael Bay's gigantic, explosive, musclebound baby.
The blockbuster auteur helmed the first five
films of the franchise to huge box office
earnings and mixed critical acclaim.
For the 2018 prequel, "Bumblebee," directing
duties were given to Travis Knight, who also
directed the animated film "Kubo and the Two
Strings."
Now, a third filmmaker will enter the franchise,
as Steven Caple Jr. is directing "Transformers:
Rise of the Beasts."
Caple made his feature-length directorial
debut with 2016's "The Land," a tale of four
teenage skateboarders earning the wrath of
a crime boss after stealing a car full of drugs.
He followed that up with "Creed II," which
saw Michael B. Jordan's titular boxer grappling
with his past and battling a Russian bruiser.
He's also worked on the TV shows "Rapture"
and "Grown-ish."
Speaking with Trey Mangum of "Shadow and Act,"
Caple explained what he's going for with "Rise
of the Beasts," saying,
"There's a lot of heart and emotion that I
draw from.
If you've seen any of my work, I love to stay
grounded, even though the scope could be here
and we're blowing up stuff."
At their core, "Transformers" stories are
about good versus evil, truth, freedom, the
importance of humanity, and doing the right
thing even when it's hard.
These themes are showcased through unlikely
heroes like Sam, Cade, and Charlie.
This will be the case again in "Rise of the
Beasts," and director Steven Caple Jr. has
made it clear he wants the movie to show that
heroes come in all different shapes and sizes.
The entire creative team is in support of
this messaging and is keen to make sure audiences
meet new heroes and aren't just getting another
version of the same old battle between the
Autobots and the Decepticons.
Producer Lorenzo di Bonaventura teased during
an interview with "Collider,"
"I wanna start by saying that what we're trying
to do with this movie is to give the audience
a lot of new.
If you've seen and been a fan of the other
movies, you're gonna see villains you've never
seen before, you're gonna see Autobots you've
never seen before, and you're gonna see a
lot of elements that we've never done before."
"Rise of the Beasts" brings a lot of new elements
to the big screen franchise, but one constant
that viewers can count on is Peter Cullen
who is back voicing the Autobot Optimus Prime.
As the strong and steady leader of the Autobots,
Optimus is the common thread throughout the
"Transformers" franchise.
But, leaning into that theme of new, viewers
are going to see a different side to him this
time around.
As a prequel, there's an opportunity for fans
to see Optimus grow as a character, since
at this stage, he's still figuring out his
place on Earth.
"You've never faced anything like this."
"Let them come."
His journey to becoming the planet's protector
is just beginning.
During an interview with "Collider," the director
said,
"In this film, it's forming why he has a link
to humanity and why he has a link to Earth,
and that's emotional.
It's not home yet to him.
He's like an ex-pat here.
He's landed, he's an alien, and he's never
been here before.
That allows us to get underneath the stoicism
of what we've traditionally presented in Prime."
And so at this stage, he's going to look less
like the Optimus from the Michael Bay films
and much more like the G1 robot viewers saw
in "Bumblebee."
As well as some returning cast members, there
are some fresh faces as well.
The new human lead characters are played by
Anthony Ramos  of "Hamilton" and
"In the Heights."
He stars as Noah.
Dominique Fishback of "Judas and the Black
Messiah" plays Elena.
Despite being new to the franchise, both actors
have long histories with "Transformers," making
them perfect for these roles.
Ramos spoke to People about his long love
of "Transformers," revealing that it was the
animated show "Beast Wars" that got him into
the franchise when he was growing up.
He said,
"I was [in front of the TV] every week watching
'Beast Wars.'
So when I read the script, I saw we were gonna
have them in the movie, my head almost exploded
off of my body."
Meanwhile, Shia LaBeouf was Fishback's window
into the "Transformers" universe.
The Disney Channel fan said in an interview
with "Collider,"
"I used to watch Shia on 'Even Stevens,' so
to watch him go from this Disney kid to this
movie star and being in the 'Transformers'
films, I was like, 'Oh, man, I wanna do something
like that!'
I couldn't imagine that almost 20 years later,
I would be doing it as well."
"Rise of the Beasts" also boasts several other
notable cast members.
The Lord of Casterly Rock himself, Peter Dinklage,
voices the villainous Scourge.
Ron Perlman plays the silverback Optimus Primal,
a character he portrayed before in the animated
"Transformers: Power of the Prime" series.
Pete Davidson takes over the role of Autobot
Mirage from the late Francesco Quinn, and
Michelle Yeoh voices Airazor.
"Optimus, we must trust each other to protect
the home we all share."
One character notably missing from this list
is Bumblebee, who was voiced by Dylan O'Brien
in his 2018 solo outing.
O'Brien's return to the franchise hasn't been
confirmed and his commitment to other features
like "Ponyboi" has no doubt been keeping him
busy.
However, a voice role in the movie is definitely
not out of the question, and viewers may just
have to wait until the film is released to
get confirmation.
To tell this new story, the creative team
behind "Rise of the Beasts" are introducing
three new robot tribes — Maximals, Predacons,
and Terrorcons — to the existing battle
on Earth between the Autobots and Decepticons.
The introduction of these new Cybertronians
will change the course of the Autobot-Decepticon
war that viewers have seen so far.
Lorenzo di Bonaventura explained to "Collider,"
"We had somewhat exhausted, I would say, [that]
battle ... So, our hope was, how do we find
a new set of villains and a new set of priorities
for the villains?"
However, the producer quickly noted that there
were lots of tribes and new characters from
the extended "Transformers" universe who had
yet to be seen on the silver screen.
The Predacons and Terrorcons fall on the side
of the Decepticons, while the Maximals are
a new tribe of heroes.
These new transformers turn into robotic animals
and birds.
Optimus Primal is the leader of the Maximals
and transforms into a gorilla-like beast.
Teasing a little more about what viewers can
expect from these animalistic heroes, Caple
explained to "USA Today,"
"In our particular film, they're these prehistoric
animals that travel through time and space,
and we find them here on Earth."
"Transformers: Rise of the Beasts" introduces
both the Predacons and Terrorcons as two new
factions of Decepticons, but one should be
feared more than the other.
In an interview with "Collider," Caples said,
"When the Terrorcons enter the screen and
disrupt our movie, you're gonna feel it."
These robots are the main villains of the
film, and they are led by Scourge, a merciless
predator who takes pleasure in stealing insignias
from the fallen Autobots he defeats.
Caple was particularly excited about including
Scourge, who was a blank slate for big-screen viewers.
He said,
"It felt like Scourge was someone that was
untapped.
That not only allowed me freedom, but it also
created this super ruthless and scary character."
Scourge's right hand is the shape-shifting
Terrorcon Nightbird.
She has been adapted from the "Beast Wars"
cartoon for the movie and, according to the
director, she's had some modifications made
to her.
She has a vehicle form that is new but also
possesses ninja traits.
Teasing more about her history, Lorenzo di
Bonaventura said,
"What I find very interesting is that she
switched sides and now she's a Terrorcon who
has joined that side of it.
Her history is one that has had flexible alliances,
which is fun."
It's pretty common for "Transformers" to explore
different locations across the globe, showcasing
how widely spread the robots have become.
They don't just exist in cities like New York
and Chicago, they also hide out in the deserts
of Egypt and Jordan, as seen in "Revenge of
the Fallen."
Meanwhile "Age of Extinction" took viewers
off to far-flung locations like China and Iceland.
"Rise of the Beasts" follows a similar pattern.
The film traverses continents, taking viewers
to locations like New York and Peru.
Additionally, the movie was filmed in a few
more places, including Los Angeles and Montreal.
However, it was the South American locations
that most excited the film's director.
He revealed to "Collider,".
"Very few films have been shot, not only in
Peru, but also Machu Picchu, and they opened
the doors for us.
I'm grateful to collaborate with Peru and
highlight Peru's culture and the ancient civilization.
They have beautiful landscapes and sites,
but most importantly, beautiful people, and
I'm excited about that."
This location is no doubt going to be important
for the character of Elena.
As a museum researcher, this may be where
she discovers one or more important artifacts
relating to the Terrorcons.
The "Transformers" movie franchise sprang
into action in 2007 when Shia LaBeouf played
Sam Witwicky, a shy but smart high school
kid.
But, with the help of Bumblebee, Optimus Prime,
and their transforming friends, as well as
Mikaela Banes, Colonel William Lennox, and
Agent Simmons, he became an earth-saving hero.
LaBeouf returned twice more with his companions,
but in his third outing, Mikaela was replaced
by his new love interest, Carly.
This was Sam and Carly's last appearance and
director Michael Bay went on to helm a new
duology starring Mark Wahlberg and Nicola
Peltz-Beckham.
After this, Travis Knight took the franchise
back a couple of decades to 1987, introducing
a younger Bumblebee to Hailee Steinfeld's
Charlie.
"Rise of the Beasts" is set eight years after
Charlie's adventures with the Transformers.
Following the emotional ending of "Bumblebee,"
which saw Charlie and Bee part ways after
saving the day together, Charlie chose to
stay with her family and friends, while Bee
had to embark on a new mission of his own.
"Goodbye, Bumblebee."
After his adventures with Charlie, Bumblebee's
new mission was to reunite the Autobots, and
it appears that in the years since, he has
done just that.
"Transformers: Rise of the Beasts" picks up
with the fan-favorite robots back together.
Discussing how the setting of 1994 came about,
producer Lorenzo di Bonaventura explained,
"We were thinking about it as a progression.
Bumblebee was in 1987, so then how do we move
it forward and also not run into the timeline
of the Bay films?
We had picked '94, in part because there was
great music during that time period, so it
felt like that natural extension."
This fits perfectly with director Steven Caple
Jr's vision for the film.
After reading the script, he felt very connected
to the time period and wanted to continue
this story.
He also noted that along with the music Bonaventura
plans to capture, there's going to be a lot
of '90s culture and aesthetics throughout
the film.
So, it sounds like viewers can expect a great
nostalgia trip from "Rise of the Beasts."
Steven Caple Jr. grew up watching the animated
"Transformers" TV series "Beast Wars," which
ran from 1996 to 1999.
And since the movie takes a lot of inspiration
from the show, it's no wonder Caple found
himself at the helm.
He told "Collider,"
"What brought me to the project was the chance
to imagine on a different level and to dream.
That's what 'Transformers' means to me.
Dealing with robots, dealing with humans,
and creating that bond, it's all about the
emotion and where we can take our new characters."
Despite the inspiration "Transformers: Rise
of the Beasts" takes from the '90s show, not
every element of it is being carried over
exactly as it was.
For "Transformers" fans who are familiar with
"Beast Wars," it's important to note that
the 2023 movie has taken some creative liberties,
including introducing a whole new crew of
voice actors.
Time travel is one element from the series
that Caple has indicated will be carried over.
However, it won't be in the same way viewers
have seen before.
The movie's timeline will differ from the
one established in "Beast Wars," which is
set 300 years in the future.
Every director brings their own ideas and
creativity to a project.
Michael Bay did this with the first five "Transformers"
films, putting his unique stamp on the franchise
and delivering on the themes of heroes and
villains, good overcoming evil, and hope overcoming loss.
But moving forward from those films, Bonaventura
said Steven Caple Jr. brought a must-needed
new perspective.
He explained,
"We were trying to accomplish a certain change
up from the movies we did with Michael [Bay].
We wanna deliver a film that has the scale
and spectacle of the Bay films with the heart
and humor that we were able to achieve in
Bumblebee."
The director's new perspective brought with
it a darker tone to the movie.
The fact that the main villains have the word
"terror" in their name should instantly instill
fear, according to the director who is planning
to take that darker energy and run with it.
He teased,
"I wanna dabble more in horror in this one
and make people jump out of their seats."
You can't stop the "Transformers."
After all, they've earned over $4.8 billion
at the worldwide box office, and they finally
got some critical cred with their last venture,
"Bumblebee."
If Paramount gets its way, "Transformers:
Rise of the Beasts" won't be the last time
these robots take over our theater screens.
In February 2022, "Collider" reported that
the official Paramount Twitter account had
announced "Rise of the Beasts" would be the
first installment of a new trilogy.
Assuming that it does solid business, chances
are good we'll see Noah, Elena, the Maximals,
and Optimus Prime back on the big screen again.
"I'm nobody.
I ain't even seen nothing.
I'm not even seeing anything right now."
A CG-animated "Transformers" theatrical film
will also follow in 2024 but is separate from
the upcoming trilogy.
The upcoming animated feature will be an origin
story for Optimus Prime and Megatron.
It will be set on Cybertron and have "Superman"
and Krypton influences, according to producer
Lorenzo di Bonaventura.
In an interview with "Collider," producer
Lorenzo di Bonaventura talked about how much
action viewers can expect to see in "Rise
of the Beasts."
He confirmed that the film will strike a nice
balance of CGI and practical elements.
This means real-life stunts, which is where
Anthony Ramos and Dominique Fishback's newly
minted driver's licenses might come in handy.
Alongside a stacked cast, there's also plenty
of talent behind-the-scenes.
Joining Lorenzo di Bonaventura and Steven
Caple Jr. is Joby Harold, who created the
story for "Rise of the Beasts" and co-wrote
the screenplay.
Sci-fi fans will know Harold best as the producer
behind the Disney+ series "Obi-Wan Kenobi."
He's also worked as a writer on DC's 2023
movie "The Flash," which is in direct competition
with this "Transformers" feature.
Additionally, "Rise of the Beasts" will be
rated PG-13 like all the other movies in the
"Transformers" franchise.